[Applause]
[Music]
you may have noticed that lately we've
been talking a lot about Argentina here
on visual politic but a portable and
you're right we've made a lot of videos
about the country of tango but well what
do you want me to say Argentina is a
very interesting country after all can
you tell me any other country this in
the last six decades on average has had
to negotiate a rescue with the IMF every
four and a half years Argentina is
essentially the country of crises Monday
8:12 2019 Argentina just suffered the
second biggest crash since 1954 any
stock market and the nation is again on
the brink of a financial crisis so that
all of the same pieces backer and el
treinta cincuenta por ciento Rijo paisa
tray siento cincuenta puntos and now
order the dollar sue vo lo que su vo
it's a Des Moines strictly embrava Ravi
I can remember a single time when
Argentina's current affairs were not
marked with economic problems
[Applause]
fiber inflation of the late 1980s the
default in the Carlito the freezing of
bank accounts at the beginning of this
century or the economic collapse that
the country has been experiencing since
2015 and which has forced it to
negotiate with the IMF yet again on this
occasion the rescue amounts to no less
than 56 billion dollars obviously having
so many economic problems has
consequences during the last hundred
years Argentina has gone from being one
of the ten richest countries on the
planet in per capita terms to tumbling
way down to sixty fourth position that
is at the level of Belarus Turkmenistan
or Iran and worst of all it's ranking
keep song falling but in recent years
the dream has spread through Argentina
and with it the hope that once and for
all they'll be able to leave their
problems behind in the 19th century war
was Argentina's cash cow at the
beginning of the last century it was
beef the famous Argentine meat in the
mid twentieth century it was Whedon's
now many hope that oil and gas will
change the country's fate and this hope
has a name
dead cow so listen up
[Music]
dead cow the latest treasure alright
welcome you do it doesn't have the
prettiest or most romantic name but
behind this name lies one of Argentina's
great treasures but hold on a second
what on earth is the dead cow deal
[Music]
that's the obvious first question dead
cow is a geological formation that can
turn this country into a gas exporting
power located on the western edge of
Patagonia near the Andes and in the
middle of an arid and lonely steppe dead
cow is the reason for news stories like
this dead cow Joon's gas production was
the highest in 11 years last month there
was a total of 140 million cubic meters
per day produced which means an annual
growth of 5.8% the largest gas
production in 11 years
by the way this isn't strictly a new
discovery the dead cow site was
discovered by American geologist Charles
Weaver back in 1931 however until
relatively recently nothing could be
done with it dead cow is an
unconventional hydrocarbon deposits that
is shale oil when oil is extracted and
shale gas when gas is extracted in this
site hydrocarbons are distributed
throughout a 30,000 square kilometer
surface area an area equivalent to twice
the size of Kuwait there's only one
problem
unlike the Middle East where you only
need to prick the soil to get oil or gas
to spout out here in dead cow territory
all those precious hydrocarbon resources
are about 3,000 metres below the surface
[Music]
so yes it's very tricky situation indeed
and hold on a second because that's not
all there is another even worse problem
in this case the oil and gas is trapped
within the rock so to exploit them a
well must be built through which a
pressurized substance is injected to
fracture the rock so that the oil and
gas can be released through that well
it's a matter of pressure when oil and
gas are released from the rocks these
compounds emerge with huge force it's
something similar to opening a shaken
bottle of soda
exactly we're talking about the
controversial fracking or hydraulic
fracture that's why they couldn't
exploit dead cow until relatively
recently now at this point there's a
question I know many of you might be
thinking exactly how much oil and how
much gas are we talking about because
well that's the key issue could the dead
cow site really represents this big
turnarounds for Argentina yes si Baca
Berta Lucy moment a trip or symptomatic
ask a serrano del dominancy que no tenia
most Abruzzo need an answer
[Music]
oxygen for the crisis
to continue this story we need to go
back to 2011 that year Repsol a Spanish
oil company announced its greatest
discovery Repsol y PF announces the
greatest oil discovery in its history
Repsol YPF
estimates that there are coverable oil
and gas resources equivalent to nine
hundred and twenty-seven million barrels
of oil matter that was only the
beginning
today dead cow is considered to be at
least the second largest unconventional
gas reservoir in the world and the
fourth largest in shale oil in fact
check it out according to the US Energy
Agency estimates this deposits current
exploitable reserves amounts to sixteen
billion barrels of oil and 308 trillion
cubic feet of natural gas but what are
these figures really equate to
[Music]
well to give you an idea 16 billion
barrels of oil equals twice the
conventional reserves of countries like
Norway or Angola it's almost 60 years of
Argentina's oil consumption and as for
natural gas
Argentina's current consumption is
approximately a trillion cubic feet per
year so to understand that better
just the exploitable reserves of dead
cow three hundred eight trillion cubic
feet of natural gas that amounts to
almost 300 years of gas consumption in
Argentina dead cow might as well be
called cash cow because the place is so
flush with oil and gas
all this means that within a few years
Argentina could have an important
competitive advantage cheap energy and
nothing suits industry better than
having cheap energy on the other hands
the country may also dove into exporting
natural gas not only to its Latin
American neighbors but also to the rest
of the world especially Asia now that's
interesting because surely most of you
are worried about sustainability and the
environments right you wouldn't like to
have renewable short-term energy sources
and for lower polluting energy sources
tab leading role however to reach this
point there's a much more urgent step
that needs to be taken replacing coal in
production processes especially in
developing countries such as China which
still generates 70% of its electricity
by burning coal
[Music]
if its enormous population and heavy
reliance on coal China is by far the
world's biggest polluter responsible for
more emissions in the US and EU combined
in this mission both for cost and
technology natural gas works like a
charm and is certainly much cleaner than
oil and coal so even if we speak in
terms of sustainability dead cow is
great news dead cow is already having
very positive consequences for the
Argentine economy
[Music]
you see the lack of investments in the
decline of old deposits of course
d'argent ena since 2008 to import a huge
amount of natural gas and oil which of
course spent a much higher trade balance
deficit and a huge exodus of dollars
from the country however now that's
beginning to change crude oil production
has run for 16 months of uninterrupted
annual growth the unconventional oil
which is increased by 47 percent already
represents 18 percent of total
production Argentina has not had to
resort to oil imports for 14 months
Gustavo Liberty gwei Secretary of Energy
for Argentina I with natural gas is a
similar story since 2017 net imports
have decreased by more than 50 percent
obviously without this change
Argentina's ongoing crisis would have
been even worse what's more if Mauricio
Macri were to get reelected the first
thing he should do is go kiss the earth
a dead cow the point is that if this
site is put to work at full capacity the
impact on the country's foreign balance
could be huge according to Carlos Olmec
higher presidents of tack patrol one of
the companies that is working on the
site we would be talking about a
positive impact of about 30 billion
dollars per year 20 billion in export
and 10 billion dollars which wouldn't be
spent on buying hydrocarbons from
outside the country and of course the
country really could use all those
dollars to overcome its external
imbalances from the imf's rescue would
go into dead cows mega rescue but hold
on a second because things are not that
straightforward
always politics one question here in the
Arab soul discovery from 2011 that we
mentioned well that huge news was
actually the beginning of many many
problems without much money involved the
then Argentinian presidents Cristina
Fernandez de Kirchner made a
controversial decision who's forcefully
nationalized the YP F company the
largest Argentine oil company in which
at the time was part of the Repsol group
suddenly the Argentine government took
over ins everything stopped after its
nationalization they had to deal with a
very long judicial process which ended
up costing the country a lot of money
and also international investments they
just completely stopped
and the oil and gas sector is one that
requires huge investments of billions of
dollars Indians the project almost
stopped
however in 2015 when Mauricio Macri came
to power the project came to life again
and a rain of millions began to exploit
this great treasure
but a lot more is still needed will
Argentine politicians allow dead cow to
develop will Argentina be able to take
advantage of this great resource well
leave your answer in the comments below
and I really do hope you enjoyed this
video please do hit that like button if
you did and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos also please do
check out our friends at the reconsider
media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode but we're not mine all
soaped this channel is possible because
of patreon and our patrons on that
platform please do consider joining them
in supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and as
always I'll see you next time
[Music]